guys i'm coming on the road i would love
to see you we've been having a blast
just go to
salvolcanocomedy.com for all tickets uh
i'm at the ryman in march 11th i uh the
next day i am at the tivoli theater in
chattanooga then we got all sorts of fun
stuff we got louisville we got
evansville we got tulsa and okc oklahoma
you've been asking me to come there i am
on the way get those right away um the
beacon theater my hometown i've been
banging that drum a lot but this will be
my first headline ever that's may 14th
and then of course i have san diego and
la may 21st and 22nd love to see you
guys please come on out folks march 10th
through the 12th i will be in
philadelphia pa
at the punchline comedy club i think
it's three shows maybe four maybe five
i think it's five i think it's five
shows you gotta come out to one of them
then on april 14th i'm going to be in
irvine california at the irvine improv
one show only 8 pm that night then i'm
heading right
down to san diego from there to do a
bunch of shows i'm going to be in austin
texas
may 20th and 21st to win four shows at
the creek and cave
come out to see all these things and
also if you're in new york city
come to joey rose's if you're interested
in stand up and comedy shows go to joe
derosa info.com for tickets and
information if you're interested in
coming to the bar and sandwich shop i've
opened go to joeyrosesnyc.com
for info and hours and everything else
and there's a new secret sandwich called
the disgusting pig
swish
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds okay sorry i have ocd
uh with with points
this guy right there
it's wild it's wild i know maybe we
could do it a pop it or i could even do
i can get away with it as long as you
just fold it in i'm a lunatic
that's all done it's done now oh my god
i'm a lunatic please tell me this is
being recorded i'm a lunatic i'm a
lunatic
yes good it's good
do not cut this out of the beginning no
cut it out do not cut this out i know i
say it all the time but let me think i'm
trying i'm trying to get hypnotized to
just lose this a man's collar you just
did that too
what does it matter these demand how do
you survive at a wedding when
everybody's got a pointy collar on i
mean it was pointing right at me i'm
right next to it
sal you said you got hypnotized about it
no i want to i'm looking into like does
that work for ocd i'll let you know okay
thank you all right folks we're here
welcome to
t-a-s-t-e bus
[Laughter]
we do chance
this is mark norman our guest for today
very funny comedian you probably know
who he is long time friend great comic a
wonderful gal
as you would say good to be here i was
promised free sandwiches but who's
counting
[Music]
wyoming whiskey uh we're here in the
rose room with joey roses we're here at
the rose room and joey roses once again
come see us sometime uh and we're they
today we are arguing
honey
versus nutella versus peanut butter a
three way babes only our second
three-way of all time oh wow sal you are
team honey i mean sorry nutella yeah
mark here is peanut butter the thing
that's gonna clearly win
and then where i'm honey yeah oh yeah
and by the way all three of these would
be great on the same sandwich i bet that
would work you think honey would go with
the chocolate though the hazelnut you do
a little drizzle of honey on the bread
and then one slab of hazel one slab of
peanut that's a hot sandwich hold on we
got a landline ring
you coming to this place you transform
it in 1988 yeah yeah
yeah now we uh i i agree we have a we
have a secret sandwich that we do here
that our cook that our chef guy puts
together i'm sorry what a secret
sandwich is off menu how do i know not
know that huh how does people know about
it people find out about it like this
because they tell people
it's not so
i believe you've had it um but it's
nutella peanut butter and then
uh salsa doritos whoa i think it's
amazing
yeah
it's amazing but i agree with you that
this was doritos
and i think honey would be nice there
you go a little honey on there it's it's
it's nutella with
it's uh chili doritos is it
salsa verde excuse me doritos um nutella
and marshmallow fluff it's amazing you
make this sandwich what's it called it
doesn't have a name it's an off-menu
sandwich chris stefano it's christian
stefano's favorite thing in the world
you gotta name it about it nutella fluff
and
salsa verde who knows
yeah nutella fluff and then salsa verde
doritos i don't see the salsa verde in
there no meat no i'm telling you it's
like a dessert sandwich meat with
chocolate and marshmallow wow i think
it's a sandwich i'm just shocked there's
no meat in it no it's a it's like a
dessert sandwich okay yeah i'm telling
you it's it's i could picture it if
you're like hi but who's putting salsa
verde
on
marshmallow and hazelnut it's a little
spicy i gotta be honest right now i
don't like the attitude you have about
this
why don't you be supportive when i tell
you it's a great story maybe you should
keep this secret sandwich a little more
secret
oh
[ __ ] good child your child
i'm a child speaking of child children
all welcome here at joey roses
[Laughter]
i wouldn't expect you to understand this
sandwich
i i i don't know because it didn't come
out of an oscar really intriguing i'm
completely intrigued
an oscar
that was the jugular right there
you got it oh you didn't like the
dracula stick around oh boy is this what
you guys do
good for a show
it's good i'm telling you i'm not i'm
not saying it's not good i'm just saying
i cannot wrap my mind around it that's
the beauty of it let's go make one right
now
right now we'll pause the video we don't
have any bread in the kitchen we're not
open today we bake our bread daily fresh
wow
like
yeah there it is
it's funny we go get some bread we can
go get some bread i mean get some bread
get some bread i wouldn't get some bread
i wouldn't put my product on somebody
else's bread don't insult me
but babe the flavor profile should it
should should proceed you know i'm
telling you
come by when we're open and i will have
our kitchen guy do it for you his name
is dave he's great and he will make you
one of these things and you're going to
be like holy [ __ ] it's incredible i'm
telling you when he told me about it i
was kind of like what i just thought it
might be fun for us three to try it no
judgement zone mm-hmm and just really
report back on it
you're telling me you can't get a fresh
loaf of bread in the lower east side uh
he's got a point there
i can throw a rock and hit a bakery baby
not like we make
not like we make not like you make where
are your bacon bread in here yeah none
of your business wow
we make our bread fresh every morning we
got ovens in here we make our bread
every morning off-site at a close by
location oh my gosh
i swear to you we make our own bread
every day no i know you do i know you do
yeah off-site though a lot of there's a
lot of secrets going on
that's the beauty of it
you know you're walking behind the
counter mcdonald's and going what's in
that secret sauce none of your business
how take it and enjoy it how do people
before this moment how do people find
out about the secret sandwich word of
mouth no we just kind of sometimes we'll
kind of whisper to people in the bar and
and we're letting it kind of do you have
someone come in off the street and be
like i'd like the secret sandwich please
chris
the stefano yeah but he's obsessed with
close to home he's obsessed we should
really name it after him
oh all right we'll call it the fat pig
the disgusting pig
that's great
that's great
oh that's so great you gotta name this
always a disgusting pig
michael che keeps pushing us to do
what he is i believe is calling the
three titty sandwich oh really and a
total recall delicious
it would be chicken breast duck breast
and turkey fries that is hysterical
[Music]
puked all those tits
sorry joey
the three titty sandwich
what's on it besides all the breasts
thank you i got as far as that and i
said mike i don't want to do this duck
brush chicken breasts and turkey breasts
i believe those were those things the
turducken did he have that i tried to uh
there you go did he has he had that or
is he just shooting off oh i think he
just thinks it's funny to have something
called a titty sandwich that's funny
like you know and then it's all breast
milk what was the movie with the arnold
schwarzenegger there it is yeah yeah
yeah
of what you just did
i did enjoy it it was a gut reaction oh
right here
there you go wow i can't spit on your
girlfriend's tits i've never seen you
care this much about anything do you
guys want to you want some fun facts
about the foods here yeah please butter
was originally made for people with no
teeth whoa whoa
i mean how do we not know that leave it
on the ground it's dirty
oh man all right joe look at you you
care about something yeah
i don't know how i feel about it either
conflicted but yeah have you have you
[ __ ] in here yet no
kids welcome
oh sorry we click let's clean it up a
little
no you can't you wouldn't have a cop
tonight would you have cop to that if
you did if i did would you have copped
to it no but i haven't right i know no i
understand that you haven't i feel like
you have to it's part of owning a place
the uh
i guess i don't know yeah i guess people
have done that right
i worked in a bar for a decade and do
you ever bang it you know no comment oh
yes
uh ian finance did say he had sex in the
bathrooms here oh wow he has claimed
that he has but i don't think it's true
that's not i don't know how come on
impress him i know we should have
financed finance would be a good a good
one he's a finicky fellow i love him
real money or trans [ __ ]
[Music]
exactly
oh wait did we do the shooter yet yeah
we did it yeah well i don't know did you
pour another one
he might have who knows all right this
is a chance we might be drunk yeah
listen to me yeah this is you you're in
two now yes you get the opening tuesdays
tuesdays with stories uh is mark's uh
podcast with joe list another one of our
dear friends who was actually on the
program right yeah and then you got uh
with sam morell you got uh we might be
drunk you just did it and you did it
yeah yeah i had a great time on that
thing both great shows great apps great
numbers are you doing tuesdays you know
in a
different studio you are in the studio
yeah and that's been a while a minute
now yeah a little bit we we just so lazy
and we half-ass we did on a couch for
eight years and then we said we gotta
get our [ __ ] together we went to a
studio numbers went way up yeah oh why
why i think it's just a visual people
people take it seriously now like oh
this is a real thing oh you see these la
guys they spend nine million on their
studios they don't do stand-up at all
yeah and uh you know they're just all
podcasting and they make millions
they're professional stand-up podcasters
yes yeah exactly yeah yeah uh we do it
in my house on the couch and uh we've
been like we gotta get us you know we're
gonna i'm building a studio but it's
gonna take a little bit yeah a week ago
in the city no no of course not in my
new home you hate to hear it you hate to
be here it's gonna be a while so what is
it west chester i mean how far away no
no no no no
she's in the area oh okay it's in the
air but we didn't break ground yet got
it so it's gonna be two years until we
become professional an outfit yeah maybe
maybe we can find ourselves let's throw
some wallpapers
maybe we find a neutral studio before
then yeah like that's in between yeah
and betwixt okay those are you garbage
guys have a pretty good lockdown over
there i just did that and i uh
appearance wise if you watch the are you
guys they're gonna be they're gonna be a
guest on this if you watch the are you
garbage guys podcast i i had to ask them
are you guys actually in a basement they
really made it look good
you guys really did too thank you so now
you have to rent that and then like
that's we own that room you
basically own it we don't wouldn't buy
it no one else goes in the room that's
your life it's a studio and you say this
is ours we're going to pay this much a
month and we get
to it yeah
the numbers work oh yeah that's what i
was gonna ask don't don't give us a
number but how pricey is it to rent the
studio space it's a couple g's yeah but
if it wasn't ours a couple's great it
would probably be like 1400 but after us
it's you know maybe 24. right
you're doing it
yeah oh yeah oh yeah what do you mean if
it wasn't you before you just went in
and rented a studio and it was a white
wall
but to make it our own oh that's a
little more money premium there you go
well you guys did a a bang-up job there
that's really really good thank you our
producers are bad it has a whole vibe in
there it sets a tone it really does it's
nice it's very comfortable i like that
place quite a bit all right my episode
came out uh two weeks ago oh no we might
be drunk you look it up you can look it
up yeah give it a whirl
yeah mine's out i had a great time what
did you drink that you must have got
ossified on what did we drink
why why must i have gotten because you
like the spirits because you gotta
you're like you're like a princess
you're like a creature
the amount of spirits yeah
you are like a preacher
that's what i call you yes yeah i'm a
drinking man you are all about the
spirits yeah but uh no i didn't get out
of that we did i did make you guys do a
couple shots that's right
um but you also made us eat that
disgusting mac and cheese ice cream it
was the most disgusting
somebody said to us we tried it on air
was horrific what brand was that was
that jack craft no it was crap oh it was
crap
give it a go
disgusting no don't you dare disparage
jenny's like that jenny's
favorite ice cream
i was i was more asking like was that
jenny's because jenny's has never made a
thing i didn't like no jenny's if you're
watching and we know that you are thank
you for sending me ice cream all the
time please keep sending it especially
all the limited edition flavors i gave
james you know you could send me some
more too i gave it jenny's i gave a
jenny six-pack to like three or four
people for christmas even wow
yeah the blackout chocolate whatever
that's called yeah yeah chocolate
nightmare you're gonna die tonight
chocolate whatever it happens
it's so good man oh my god i gotta try
this talk to me about the the drunkest
app you've had on we might be drunk so
far oh well was it was it like
you couldn't collect yourself did you
get there yet well we do sometimes we do
two in a day so you drink a glass of
scotch or two on the first one the
second one you're doing martinis and
you're like oh what do we talk about how
about that
actually negatively affects it oh yeah
well the fans like it they love it like
they're getting hammered they're
slurring all that [ __ ] you start talking
about girls you [ __ ] and you're your
dad hitting you and it just gets sick
you start
that's a podcast we should start yeah
and compete with guys i like it somehow
we'll get in trouble probably probably
yeah they didn't cancel
when they do it it's empowering
they're going to be by the way the guys
we [ __ ] girls uh karen my friend
christina dear friends they're they're
they want to come on we're trying to get
them off well
i know you would think you could talk to
them
today so they couldn't come today oh
right now the the uh jessica kirsten
wants to come on that's a good one yes
and uh and the argue garbage guys want
to come on yeah yeah we have some fun
and roy wood's going to come on we got a
whole bunch of great guests down the
pike yeah yeah totally all right great
anyway sorry so i just want to say
me and sam to a drinking podcast we're
coming out with our own rye
so
unbelievable bread
huh bread
spread the love what take me through it
did you think when you named the podcast
we might be drunk was this already in
the in the in the chamber or did you
conceive of the idea after the podcast
and then you conceived of the idea
who's the first person you call well
that's like a lot of great questions
there fatty what we did was we had uh
all right all right now you're right so
you know i've been a smoker for many
years i do uh and i recently have cut
back significantly
but how do you still get a nicotine
because you need a nicotine assistant
you have something to assist you in
cutting back from the actual sigis
that gives you the nicotine buzz you
need and that's where lucy comes in well
i mean i people i mean i when i was a
smoker i use nicotine to relax i think
that's how a lot of people uh you know
use nicotine to relax focus or unwind
lucy is a modern day oral nicotine
company that makes nicotine gum lozenges
and pouches for adults who are looking
for the best
most responsible way to consume their
nicotine lucy it's not a means to quit
lucy it's a means to hopefully help you
cut down in my case i cut down and
stopped lucy lucy
lucy and then this is different from the
lucy on on the old uh charles schultz
cartoons
this is not a lucy that's gonna put
something uh intriguing in front of you
like a football and then pull it away
and cause you to make a fool of yourself
this is a lucy that's actually going to
deliver and help you with what they're
promising if you enjoy using nicotine
you should definitely check out lucy's
products at lucy.co that's co that's
lucy lucy.co and use promo code
tastebuds at checkout they have uh gums
they have packs they have different
flavors yes and i have to read this
disclaimer warning this product does
contain nicotine
nicotine is an addictive chemical okay
that is a fact but remember if you're
interested in a better way to use
nicotine use lucy.co
visit it and be sure
to use the promo code tastebuds okay
that's simple that's simple
lucy.colucy.co
and use our promo code
buds yes
guys i want to talk to you about sunday
lawn care because we are heading into
spring and let's face it i can't wait to
feel that grass underneath my toesies
it's hard to imagine but it's almost
here and we're so close to feeling it
and uh we got to get our lawn back so if
you're worried about all the chemicals
you're using to keep your yard looking
its best because traditional uh lawn
care actually lays down tons and tons 90
million pounds which i don't know how
who weighed that but of pesticides each
year but that's true sunday's different
so what they're doing is they're on a
mission to change how people care for
their yards it's sunday
uh you know you don't have to worry you
have to choose between having a
beautiful art yard and keeping your
family out of harm's way with that kind
of stuff most of us might not think
about our lawns in the winter but this
is the time to prep
you're probably thinking you have so
much work to do to get it green and
healthy again but sunday does take care
of all the work it takes to work out for
you okay sunday can help you grow a
beautiful lawn without the guesswork
or the nasty chemicals and that's the
top line right there the custom uh plans
include fertilizer and everything you
need to easily care for your lawn and
with ingredients like seaweed iron and
molasses
you can feel good with kids and pets
being around
all you gotta do is visit sunday.com put
in your address and their lawn analysis
tool does the rest they then use soil
and climate data to create a personal
nutrient plan we are in the future folks
deliver to your door when you need it
that is wild that is a customized lawn
care plan based on your address right to
your door take out the guesswork make it
safer just attach the ready-to-use pouch
to a garden hose and spray it takes less
than 15 minutes so that's how you can
apply it best of all it truly truly
works sunday of course is offering our
listeners 20
off full season plans start at just 129
bucks that's for the full season and you
get 20 off at checkout when you visit
getsunday.com
tastebuds20 that's 2-0 again that's 20
off your custom plan at get sunday dot
com slash taste buds 2-0
it's like a lot of great questions there
fatty what we did was we had a
uh we hit this podcast and started
picking up a little steam and then we
said we should get merch what's a good
merch what did we put it out to the
crowd and then somebody said why don't
you sell booze and we went yeah ron
white's got a whiskey clooney's got a
whiskey all these guys
tequila sorry clooney's got a tequila
why can't we do that yeah they both
well i can't give that away
all right
but it's a very new york centric name
it's going to be a rye we tasted about
50 rise
i just i just said the n word but um
it's uh
you said nothing which is so odd because
i i will keep it well the mic was up
there i was worried it would catch it
okay
wait tell me oh it was better than i
could have thought of a sweater god
it's not as good as secret sandwich tell
me yeah it's a hell of a name
it's a disgusting pig sandwich
it's a really good name it's a really
good name oh that's very good that's
good good dude who thought of it that's
good uh
i don't know maybe sam he's a new yorker
yeah and uh so we went for that whole
new york city vibe and it'll be fun now
how do you who do you call and how do
you uh go through the process of the
taste the flavor profile what what you
think is good and ready to go and send
to market how do you do that we
announced that we might be doing it the
phone rang off the hook we'll do it
we're in montauk we're in new hampshire
where and i did a gig in houston once
and a guy was like hey do you want to
come see my distillery and i was like
sure a free tour and free booze so we
just went with that guy and he's gonna
make the whiskey and we've been doing
the label back and forth with bottle
shape all the questions you want cork
you want screw what do you want you know
small batch oh yeah that's great that's
great that's awesome
and that is a new york-centric name oh
yeah so
when you decided on the name
the damn jews in my neighborhood whiskey
cats out of a bag folks
mel gibson is a sponsor
i'm sure to leaky yeah but sugar tips
the whoopi goldberg whiskey
yeah
no that's great dude that's exciting
we'll see how it goes i mean it could be
a flop but we figured what's the swap i
mean what is it what are you gonna lose
a hundred grand you know what i mean
like it's like
first
why would you say that like it was like
it was nothing no no no it that would be
something i'm saying they're not gonna
lose
were like a house
worst case scenario it was a hundred
grand
it's a flop is like what if these
t-shirts don't see you know what i mean
it's a fun merch thing you're doing
that's awesome like that's been you yeah
no it's an investment but it'll you'll
make your money you put everything up
front and do they make the batches so
are you buying the bottles via the
batches ahead of time because they have
to produce them and so you're buying the
inventory no matter what it's not being
made to order per se right it is it's
being made for us for us so if you get
an order for you know uh okay you get
500 orders you then
tell them make 500 oh so so your risk is
low very low and we're on a pocket every
week so we have a promotion every week
and we're going to bring it on the road
so you're going to sell the whiskey on
the road i'm doing the irvine improv
send them
cases then you do a hey we got a special
tonight the morel
shot or whatever if it's out in time
send a case when i'm at the irvine
improv i'm only doing one show let's
just try to push it as a party let's do
it i'd love to know we'll send a box
here too please send the box here please
you should get placement at a comedy
club or multiple clubs why don't you go
to all the clubs in the city and say hey
there's wyoming i love it wyoming is uh
is
it's a bourbon and it's one of their
these are our guys we love these guys
and we carry jack as well we carry a lot
of whiskeys but my point is is uh we're
not married to any particular rye so if
we were i would love it to be your rye
let's do it you know this tj miller has
a peanut butter
he brought us his peanut butter and his
hot sauce i knew that guy was nice
[Laughter]
to tell her big fan of joey rose's
because i love it quite a bit let's take
a timeout we have our own peanut butter
oh that's right you stupid [ __ ] i
have two peanut butters and a beer
my face is on the label everyone
mentioned our peanut butter
by the way she hit us up again she wants
to do a new run and a new flavor
shout out saratoga peanut butter the
best peanut butter in the land babe i
for i have never mentioned our peanut
butter to our kitchen we got the no
pressure pack you could buy the are you
are you insane you know
sandwiches with your own peanut butter
oh my god what a disgrace oh my gosh
look at this that's the third time you
knocked those cards off today
he doesn't like things on the floor
we got a taste buds peanut butter and we
have a hey babe peanut butter and by the
way thousands of dollars
for a charity yeah wow
i gotta say
taste buds peanut butter is better
ours was a butterscotch peanut butter
which is how it should be and it was
a wonderful little not too but sweetness
to it and then the other peanut butter
by the way this is all good stuff it's
all good
the hey vape is good too it's a white
chocolate blueberry peanut butter
it's very good but the but the taste
buds is better that sounds amazing it's
good baby
before i came so i am did you
should have let us know i'm joking about
if i had an edible right now i'd be
crying in the corner holding up
blueberries speaking of blueberries
before we get into today's battle
speaking of blueberries i went with sal
up to albuquerque blueberries last night
organic
good right before bed
it's a superfood yeah it is it is that's
not what i was gonna talk about okay
congrats all right
i just mentioned it because a lot of
times blueberries are too tart and these
were perfect oh i love a good not too
tart and they when they have a real pop
to them like a snap on the skin yeah
um we uh we went up to albany you were
doing shows at all but you and i
yesterday was very fine the egg
oh i love the egg yeah it was wonderful
really really popular
no good no bad seat in there no it was
very fun only good thing about albany
but on the on the way up
i went to uh a convenience store and i
said i'm going to buy some road snacks
oh i brought some of that for you i
didn't want it in the house oh my god
yeah so tate's cookies some of the best
cookies out there yeah too hard if you
ask me i think really perfect i like the
snap i love i love it i love the crumble
i love it i love it butter is
your clothes are covered in the cookie
dance that's that's the dance you're
doing all right you know what i mean
trying to get cookie monster on the show
by the way
that's like saying now the ribs they put
sauce on your face oh yeah that's ripped
the uh but here's the thing
i'm not joking
we're trying to get cookie monster on
the show
on our show no no tell them what the
hell you were talking about yeah on
taste i mean on uh impressions
yeah yeah is that is that nuts
in talks wow yeah you brought up cookies
like i just i couldn't wait where he
would like be part of the pranks with
you guys correct
how the hell is that that's it
how the hell are you gonna do that well
we have a way to do it babe okay i think
i'm gonna just [ __ ]
not know what i'm doing doesn't sound
like you know what you're doing stay
tuned how does that feel sweeps week
this is how i felt when you were talking
about my sandwich yeah
yeah
yeah so i was like i'm not gonna [ __ ]
stuff salsa verde chips up on that oh
yeah yeah
have a puppet go steal milk out of a
woman's cart in the supermarket and then
act like
it's a really a thing that's not
probably no problem
that's real yeah that's real yeah anyway
you sound like you sound like my great
aunt i'm talking do your little skits
what are you doing you're talking to a
sock puppet there couldn't possibly be
hidden cameras around me right now
he's not gonna be
walking around the city trying to make
people he's real he's just involved in a
thematic way and he's behind the scenes
and he's going to be up in the booth
he's going to be on the boat
no yes tell the people
it's not a real person this is psychotic
no it is a real person underneath the
puppet just have the guy that does the
puppet stand-in oh that's fun nobody
likes that yeah
that's fun no give me a break give me a
break give me a break piece of that
kickback
that's it we went tate shout out tates
right southampton great cookies i know
we we went without the shout outs
of southampton when i did not know this
hampton adversity you're all horrible
people
what i didn't know was hey donovan dude
tates has been doing i didn't know this
tata has been doing special edition
cookies like limited run cookies now
after we got this one that i'm going to
talk about i went online and looked it
up they've got several that sound
amazing and they're hard to find because
they're limited editions but we got
blueberry cookies
and it was basically the chocolate chip
cookie dough but it with with
blueberries in it
and dude this thing you open that bag in
the front seat
do you remember uh no i'm just you know
what i'm talking about
always i know it's a long time
didn't knee deep in this blueberry he
opened the car he opened the bag of
these cookies in the front seat
it smelled like we opened a muffin
bakery yeah
i i was so full from dinner that we had
backstage i was like i can't i have to i
give to give me one dude i can't resist
yeah
they're so good wow oh my god they're so
good yeah well let's dial it back yeah
but we're not making any money off this
you don't think they taste like bacon i
don't like them they taste like bacon
bacon the blueberry taste the taste the
base foundation of the cookie tastes
like meat oh god it tastes like a
delicious crunchy buttery treat
interesting bacon huh speaking of bacon
peanut butter honey and nutella oh yeah
all right let's do the battles
where are we at we're we're at 25
minutes oh good i think we should do the
chance
ready yeah so what happened was and
we'll just
do more i need to know with a chance
joe loves chance
no way well we used to come away from
these sometimes and he was a little
scorned because we really get heated
yeah and he'd go home and carry it with
him but i said it's for entertainment
joe let it go you do carry a lot on
that's why your shoulders are gross
[Laughter]
look at those shoulders those ski slopes
i know straight down yeah i thought
about getting shoulder implants at one
point those exist you could just work
out joe you're a handsome fellow you're
a tall dark and handsome fellow stop it
the face is fine it's just the rest
women don't seem to mind
by the way shoulder implants are twenty
thousand dollars
how much shoulder implants are good oh
wow you're quick
just you gotta get them together what
are your shoulders yeah yeah they walk
in one day they're getting everything
yeah
what are they even what are shoulder
implants okay god bless you
yeah joe
would take home a lot of this negative
energy after the fight and so he decided
that we would do a chant before we
started the fight
and uh it actually has worked and i
asked i think that maybe doing this
chant has kept us from becoming as
heated as we used to be it's just a
theory they say singing in synchronicity
or whatever you call it synchronized
singing it bonds people because you look
and everybody's singing the same time
you see the mouthing yeah it's a good
way to buy i've never seen
[Music]
there you go all right that's good
ready yes no matter what happens i love
you no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you
all right
you know i'm gonna use that
i wish my parents did that here we go
[Laughter]
you want to react at the same time
yeah exciting job they hate each other
uh one more one more chant ready yes
it's time to be a t t l e buds all right
yeah yeah yeah
that's it
yeah new merch mark we as the guests
would like you to start us off give your
opening arguments to why you think
peanut butter is the greatest spreadable
thing to put on bread peanut butter is
great it's versatile first of all you
get the smooth and the crunchy and extra
crunchy yeah they thought of everything
i never saw that it's great on bread
it's great on a tortilla
it's great everywhere disgusting it
works on a tortilla flatbread or on a
tortilla like a uh what do you call it
like a soft tortilla yeah but just flour
you just just that on the tortilla yeah
it works
it's like a crate okay it's like a crack
okay all right all right and i eat it
every day with oatmeal i uh you can eat
it with chocolate so you get like a
reese's thing
it's the best peanut butter cookies are
great peanut butter ice cream is great
peanut butter milkshake underrated it's
fantastic hold on it's a power but just
put it on an apple put it on a celery
you can eat it with a spoon yeah i'm not
a fan of putting it on uh vegetarian
vegetation okay i've never liked that
but but let me ask you this when you say
peanut butter milkshake you mean peanut
butter chocolate milkshake you can do
both but but what do you do is what i'm
asking i guess i go peanut butter
chocolate but peanut butter enhances
it's the bacon of of spreads i love i
love peanut butter in an ice cream
chocolate
ben and jerry's really are the kings of
putting implementing peanut butter into
it let's call a spade a spade peanut
butter is a powerhouse unless you're
allergic to peanuts i have never met
someone who is not allergic to peanuts
that was not all in on peanut butter
good point okay so you're coming in here
swinging i'd like to just throw this in
there the average european eats less
than one tablespoon one tablespoon of
peanut butter a year ah dirty frogs
polox
krauts wait wait wait wait why is this
why are europeans peanut butter adverse
well have you seen what the british
people eat they're hideous get your
teeth fixed yeah
we have a lot of uk fans
okay long live the queen england i love
england but it could have the worst
cuisine yeah easily
it's rough just says in comparison to
americans who eat three pounds a year
hell yeah three pounds is nothing i'm
taking a lot of three pounds is three
jars isn't a jar 16 ounces it is yes it
is three pounds is three jars you go
through probably a jar a month i get the
big boy the
costco yeah three oh my god i mean i'm
eating 20 pounds of people
why why do they eat less than a teaspoon
i don't let me google the average jar is
12 ounces of peanut butter
kids over there it's a whole different
world
come on down to joey
rose's sorry
come on europe's got some problems
they're racist they throw bananas on the
field it's a lot over there i don't even
know there's a lot going on oh i'll tell
you all about that later yeah there's a
lot going on in europe yeah but i do
agree that uh uh is strange that the
peanut butter isn't a tablespoon or
teaspoon well i will say this though
that one simple i like i like peanut
butter i like peanut butter peanut
butter and bananas elvis favorite
sandwich just love him i love it his was
fried
and then grabbed something you could
drizzle honey on
hold on true but couldn't care less
about peanut butter bananas but here's
the thing again i don't like oh yeah
but here's the thing i like peanut
butter quite a bit i love peanut butter
and jelly yeah same i've had the same
jar peanut butter for
18 months easily really tell that to
your body you know
this is this is ribs and fried chicken
oh that'll do it too by the way guys
it's saying they don't grow peanuts in
europe oh there you go where do they
grow peanuts pimp i guess here okay but
we eat avocado at the edge we don't grow
it here good point points good we're
actually shut down we're not buying any
more avocados because the cartel took it
over i heard that oh yeah that's like
people but diamonds now
eat right
i can live without it avocado outside of
a guacamole once in a while with my
tacos i don't care oh i think it's a
silky addition to a lot of different
elements yeah someone we're here to
argue i'm just saying i'm not saying all
right so peanut butter you're coming in
here like muhammad ali with the peanut
butter thank you okay you're coming in
here later but i will say mine is a
little more niche what i'm going for is
a little more niche insurance j is a
staple of american culture it's my
favorite sandwich of all time really
yeah yeah that yep peanut jelly
all right
so i didn't know this is a drinking pop
it's not oh okay you're here we're
honoring you a podcast your show came in
shotgun today
one of the guys
one of the guys that jumped off of the
building during the crash on wall street
he looked so stressed and i was like
dude oh you're all right buddy
you know it is what it is i hear you it
happens everything's great okay don't
get me wrong i couldn't i couldn't be
more lucky and great
but uh
in short another one of the jokers is
getting divorced has to leave the show
they're down to two chapters oh now
we're down
[Laughter]
it's me kermit piggy an animal it's down
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'll tell you what happened we actually
found out that maybe cm couldn't do it
yeah and uh we i this is like you're the
name of your thing i can't really say
who we're going for right now but if you
cut it out pimp yeah yeah you could beat
me
beat me right now and then i'll just
have the reaction this is good
we're going for
whoa yeah
[Music]
what do you mean you goddamn commercial
what would make you happy tell me what
would matter what if you're happy not a
fan get the [ __ ] out of here not a fan
to the point that when we do q a
episodes of my other podcast people
frequently say joe do you still hate
blank no
it's not your wallet deep cut it's a bit
of a nostalgia like three people are
gonna get it you might as well have
howard the duck yeah that would be great
too oh well there we go but we we're
booking guests that we think are
interesting and organic to us and we
grew up right now i thought you were
going to hit me with a kermit or
something man now kermit you can't get
your hands on [ __ ] kermit who do you
think you are he's in demand kermit
that's like getting pete davidson yeah
sal can you please get joe on please
watch out
yeah well we're doing a thing so
why aren't you by the way you have the
funniest friends on planet earth you're
bringing puppets into this goddamn thing
i want to do it because i want to throw
a curveball i'm being [ __ ] come on
have different one have norman have big
j on roy
all right sure i'll have ever all you
want but yeah i'm going to have you on
over
no way
you think i would you want to you think
you'll be a better guy
you want to send you want to send a guy
into a coffee shop to cause some trouble
you're going to think there's anybody
better than me
none of them know who i am and i'll act
like a prick and we'll get one point
having an overall guest to help with the
punishment like like a bigger like a
celebrity guys but like as far as in the
show whenever we need an extra hand any
of us the new rules any of us could call
in anybody we want let's go back
we're doing a halal guy yeah
yeah let's get a little promotion for
the podcast yeah yeah all right all
right all right all right anyway
nutella sorry i'm going nutella okay
nutella now if you're not italian it
doesn't matter it's big in the italian
community which i only i'm only half but
er because everyone thinks i'm just like
uh you know
they just slur me they think i'm sal
from staten island you someone like you
will just say ah that's an italian
guinea
[Music]
yeah so
so uh nutella though has crossed over
nutella has crossed over at this one
compliment uh second to jelly to peanut
butter it is nutella nutella is also
standalone just like peanut butter
nutella's nutella shake nutella
cheesecake nutella pie nutella
chocolates nutella infused everything it
is permeated it's more of a niche
product but i think
since it contains chocolate and
chocolate is a powerhouse that cannot be
denied hazelnut it is hazelnut i think
that i have a fighting chance i think i
have a fighting chance because we we we
post choose one i will say this to you
yeah and wait pimp go ahead we also
found that there's nutella soap
oh yeah they they jumped the show yeah
that's that greedy i will say this to
you i will say this i don't want to
smell like a hazelnut they did put
hazelnut on the map i didn't even know
what a hazelnut was until nutella i
gotta be honest with you it bugs me that
they say hazelnut it's chocolate it's
full of hazelnuts no it tastes like
hazelnuts it's not just chocolate but
it's what i'm saying it's when you eat
nutella your first thought isn't
chocolate now sure
permeated you know like
nutella is now becoming pop culture it's
even getting into clothing things like
that yeah
listen nutella is great and i will say
this is a huge pro in support of nutella
folks i want to welcome a new sponsor to
the show policy genius
policy genius
if someone uh relies on your financial
support you know maybe it's a child
maybe it's an aging parent maybe it's a
business partner you're going to need
life insurance because life insurance
can give you peace of mind that if
something happens to you
your loved ones have a financial cushion
for you know rents mortgage payments
loans whatever they might be depending
on you for assistance with
or maybe other things having life
insurance through your job may not be
enough okay most people need up to 10
times more coverage
than their jobs are giving them to
properly provide for their families and
typically life insurance gets more
expensive as you age
that's the rub isn't it
terrible so
point is smart to get your policies
sooner than later and that's where
policy genius
it's better to get your policies sooner
than later and that's where policy
genius steps in all right it's your
one-stop shop to find
and buy the insurance you need they're
not an insurance company they assist you
in finding and buying
insurance so i want you to click the
link in the description
or head to policygenius.com tastebuds
that's p o l i c y g e n
i u s dot com taste buds and you're
gonna answer a few questions and then in
minutes you can compare personalized
quotes from top companies so you can
find the lowest possible price you could
save 50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius the
team of licensed experts at policy
genius will help you understand your
options and they're going to help you
apply for the policy you choose all
right so
here's the thing
they don't add
extra feeds they don't sell your info to
third parties
they've got thousands of five stars uh
reviews across google all right
there's they have options that offer
coverage in as little as a week
since 2014 policy genius has helped over
30 million people shop for insurance and
placed over 120 billion dollars in
coverage so
again head to policygenius.com
to get your free life insurance quotes
and see how much you can save
policygenius.com tastebuds to get your
free life insurance quotes and see how
much money you can save folks
you know what we do it no fresh we keep
it fresh we keep it fresh at no press
it rhymes but it is also what we do and
how do we keep it fresh why do we keep
it fresh really is the question
because it's the best way to stay
motivated because you don't want to burn
out doing the same thing over and over
and over especially when it comes to
exercise and that's why peloton
is a great way to go all right
i'm telling you something peloton
they're helping you keep things
spontaneous new every day so you keep
going back to that exercise
routine it's a dirty word routine but
with peloton it's not really a routine
it's it's an exercise an
exercise uh they've got a lot of new
offerings uh that they're adding to the
lineup okay uh
boxing which is pretty cool they're
stepping into the ring with a new
discipline and no gloves are needed uh
discover a fast and furious and fun
workout with the peloton instructor of
your choice they've got new artist
series music selections peloton is
adding a bunch of new artist series
classes in other words so you can work
out to the music of a single artist for
an entire class and hear your favorite
hits and the deep cuts and all the stuff
you love
there's going to be more daily workout
variety they've got a ton now and
there's even more coming so it's easier
to stick to your goals when you keep
your workouts interesting
pelton is a workout for every day and
every schedule de-stress from a long day
with 30 minutes of strength and 20
minutes of cardio or hey do a quick 15
or
a quick 15 total body workout i love
that man i love a 15er all right so
here's what i want you to do
visit one peloton.com to learn more
visit onepeleton.com
to learn more nutella is great and i
will say this is a huge pro in support
of nutella
nutella is the new apple butter i have
never seen a secondary spread since
apple butter that did the damage that
hotel is doing on the scene right now
butter's not even on the map if you ask
me what is apple butter you never had
apple butter no apple butter was like
the nutella of its day it was like what
day
it's like this weird like sweet
how would you describe it it's kind of a
molassesy appley spread
and you would put it on peanut butter
times you would put it with marshmallow
flour you put it just on bread it was
the nutella of its day when nutella came
out i remember thinking oh this is kind
of like
this is like apple butter it doesn't
taste like it
yeah it was a huge thing
nothing on nutella nutella it hit the
moon yeah apple apple is it tastes like
apple and butter really a little a
little bit
but apple butter was apple butter was
like the vegemite of the united states
apple butter is almost like an apple
cider nutella kind of yeah there you go
but i mean nutella came in it was like
when the let's put this away when
nutella dropped as far as secondary
spreads are concerned when nutella
dropped it was the iphone drop
it was i remember russ maniv packing a
great comic if you have a chance to see
me hilarious but uh when the television
remember when the iphone dropped russ
maniev said to me have you ever seen
anything
revitalize an industry like this device
like he goes it's crazy it's crazy like
nothing could [ __ ] with it that's what
nutella did with with secondary spreads
yeah marshmallow fluff yeah
uh apple butter people were like whoa
i'm going honey yeah because i think
honey is is a classic test of time
classic test of time i mean honey ain't
going nowhere and you want to talk about
versatility allow me to appreciate i was
gonna say you you do have the uh power
that him and i don't have in this
argument whereas honey is a drizzle on a
sandwich we're we're sandwich components
i'm a confectionary uh he's mostly
sandwich but it would be getting to
everything else but honey i will hit you
in tea and it's i'm gonna hit you with
yeah yeah well it's my thing so let me
say it
yeah
i will no longer prompt you i will no
longer say no no no i know i'm just i'm
just no no we're not broadcasters thank
god for that
honey
[Laughter]
it's getting heated honey and tea
there's no better latency you mean the
thing that you took coffee against when
i told you
yeah
yeah
coffee hold on there's no better
late-night drink than a cup of sleepy
time tea with honey in it right before
bed number one you can put honey on
toast great uh you can put honey honey
serves as an amazing base for so many
marinades and sauces i love to cook and
you cook with something that's got honey
and chili peppers in it for instance
i mean you just switch off to the races
you're off to the races you can put it
on a sandwich as we've as we've
established with peanut butter let's be
honest
i'm using it as a staple of my cooking
constantly no let me constantly in
cooking not cooking yeah who cooks with
honey no that's what i just said like as
a base for like marinades
like a barbecue or a honeymoon
okay i could get it mustard forget it
but i'm not gonna go into honey mustard
i'll stay on whatever but that's not
honey that's honey mustard that's why i
said i'm not gonna get honey mustard
without mustard
or without honey but i'm not going to go
into that but i'm going to hit you with
the heavy i'm going to hit you with the
he winnie the pooh might have put honey
on the map well that's right that's also
true you got a whole cartoon character
based around honey calm down kids yeah
try to get him on jokers
i like to get roger rabbit that'd be fun
or i could just get you to do this
break me in
how about that jessica i'm gonna hit you
with you it holds up
jessica holds up yeah why would she she
has an age yeah she's like i'm gonna hit
you with i'm gonna hit you with my
heaviest use of honey
that's no oh by the way honey on bacon i
mean get out of here dude i never had it
it's so good but anyway i'll hit you
with my head honey on pancakes i mean it
just it goes all right honey in your
holes
i have a factory i'm just but hold on
let me go real quick yeah listen to me
i'm just hitting you with versatility
i'm not saying you're an opera
something like that but i will honey one
of our sponsors by the way hey
oh yeah damn sponsored in a while
but i'm gonna hit you with my heaviest
use of honey blizz
fried chicken you dip a chicken nugget
or a piece of fried chicken and honey
but how are you actually doing that once
a year
every time i eat chicken nuggets
once a week okay as you can tell by my
physique let me tell you this right now
i believe it granted this doesn't help
my nutella argument but you're telling
him that a a drizzle on fried chicken
which is an occasional thing is going to
somehow stack up to peanut butter
ain't that an occasional no i all i said
was my most prominent use of honey it's
what i enjoy honey with the most by the
way the body has trouble breaking honey
down by the way by the way i'll give you
something that neither of your items get
into alcoholic beverages honey is a key
part of the hot toddy peanut butter
whiskey uh peter screwball
the screwball we carry here
chocolate drinks nutella i can make a
nutella martini to blow your bowls
right now but what i'm saying to you is
this
there is peanut butter whiskey and it's
great but it's peanut butter flavored
whiskey sure honey itself in its raw
form right
into a hot toddy goes into
many drinks agreed honey gets dumped
directly into iced tea even you know
what i mean like you're not dumping
peanut butter or nutella straight up
into a drink you've got to reduce it
you've got to make a syrup out of it you
got to do something first i don't want
to help could please go well here's the
problem with honey though
it takes a lot of time to make honey you
can make nutella and peanut butter buy
the gallon all day long in a factory you
need a couple of
yellow and blacks to get together and do
a comb and all that [ __ ] and now it
takes years you gotta go through a cave
i feel like that doesn't i feel like
that's quite the opposite i feel like
you go into a bee you know beekeeper's
world or whatever on his farm whatever
the hell you call it it's a farmer and
you pull out the honeycomb and you
scrape the honey off that's it you're
there you gotta make that stunning
factory
it's more natural but i think it takes
them years to make like a tablespoon of
honey i will tell you something really
quick mr rogers once and to this day uh
one of my oldest friends in the world
his name is dominic panford who's mr
rogers mr rogers the the kid mr rogers
the show what do you mean my
neighborhood welcome to my neighborhood
you're joking right
mr rogers
no
the children's tv show mr rogers with
the cardigan
i don't know mr are you joking right now
wow what kind of childhood you have wait
scroll back a little bit was that a
picture of me you watched alf too much
you missed out on some quality
television wait a minute this is insane
what is what is it what is this is this
is something right now
so your 70s 80s this was huge this is a
revolutionary show
tom hanks played this man in a movie you
don't know who mr rogers is no no
holy [ __ ] anyway mr rogers i i i
was scared sometimes i just like to do
that that was fun i convinced i once
convinced the honest i i swear to god
for a good 20 minutes that i never heard
a diet coke
never heard a
how hard corduroy
is to make peanut butter okay mr rogers
did this on the show once and to this
day my fr one of my oldest friends
dominic pam files
curse his last name
curses mr rogers for telling us to do
this as kids he said you could make
peanut butter at home by yourself
right this little bite george washington
carver
he did it
he got butter he had actual butter and
peanuts ah and so rogers did it smashed
it all together and said that that was
how you made peanut butter on the show
and we did it and it was [ __ ]
disgusting yeah hippie [ __ ] yeah that's
crazy you know what i'm gonna give a
down vote to the peanut butter with the
goddamn oil on the top and you gotta
stir it
and it always comes back up the oil and
then when you mix it it's just too oily
it's like and then you're trying to get
to the bottom the bottom is like cement
i don't want the work i try mixing you
always you start splashing oil
i like the chemical [ __ ] i want to hold
a jiff upside down it'll never move in
100 years where are you going in the
main where are you going in the big
hitters you're going skippy you're going
jiff you're going peter pan who else we
got jeff is king
i agree jeff is
[Music]
skippy is the number one seller you're
just saying jeff is king to you no i'm
saying i think
is my curveball i think jiff is the
number one i think skippy is second
place
this is like arguing you know uh
yeah exactly oh yeah it's going strong
still out this i'm missing i'm missing
i'm missing a mainstream peanut butter a
scarf at a peter pan i'm missing a
mainstream peanut butter there's the the
nature's home or whatever no it's a
mainstream did you get skippy jiff
yep um
peter pan's still up there and then it
goes to nutella goober goober goober is
the hershey does one goober is the uh
hunters that's the one
goober is
does the uh
jelly peanut butter mix in the one jar
oh yeah i'll tell you what's wrong i'm
still going right right
oh yeah yeah i'm not taking out two
knives
i'll tell you what's wild is that the
planter's peanut butter is not the
leading brand of peanut butter these
guys are the king of the peanut yeah
yeah but he's got a peanut butter
on the peanut butter yeah but he puts on
airs he's got he's got a he's a little
bit honest
he's pretentious yeah yeah i don't need
to i don't need you to [ __ ] put on
top there's only one way to eat the most
common nut yeah
there's only one brand of nutella
correct nutella yeah and i don't want to
give you uh any credence to your
argument about honey but don't bees like
save the planet or something like that
they do without the bees would be ruined
yeah so
look i think as far as powerhouses go
peanut butter's gonna take the cake in
the argument i think as far as
versatility goes honey hands down and i
think as far as a speech a niche
interest nutella is your is your man but
nutella is the cult following let's be
honest look this is the nutella fans are
laying in the basement drinking the
poison cooling let me ask you a question
it's a cult you're looking at a table
you're coming to joey rose's there's a
little spread back here little things
that chips uh crackers whatever you got
a thing of peanut butter a single
nutella thing of honey where are you
dipping your cracker in first because
for me it's nutella i'm peanut butter
all day yeah but you can also get a
peanut butter cracker you can't get a
nutella cracker okay i'll tell you
something right now and maybe you'll
agree
honey on its own
could really [ __ ] just [ __ ] off no i
couldn't
i like honey in my nut cheerios sure i
like honey in my tea i like honey and my
mustard but you ever take a scoop of
honey and put in your mouth it's not
good well i will say this i'll say the
same thing about peanut butter i hate a
spoon what
no oh i won today no way
no way sometimes when i it's late at
night i don't want to eat bad but i want
to feel sweet but i want to feel
satiated i want the protein i throw a
spoonful of peanut butter it really
helps and i don't want to get on board
with you i do that too as a benign way
of making myself not hungry anymore i'm
not enjoying honey peanut butter
skippy honey peanut butter that's true
it's my favorite skippy peanut butter is
honey peanut butter you know how they
got mr ed to talk peanut butter yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah they put it on as
they put it all on his lips and gums
i don't know i i i get you i do that
peanut butter trick too but it's not an
enjoyable what if i throw a scoop of
nutella into a skippy honey peanut
butter and mix it up what happens then
it'll be amazing world's colliding
three things together would be fantastic
it does say honey's the most like
nutrient nutrient-dense foods that i
agree it's natural that's why yeah raw
honey my dad puts a scoop of it in his
apple cider vinegar and does a shot of
it
he's done it forever
honey's one of the rare foods that
includes all elements this is to sustain
life enzymes water minerals and vitamins
well they can never go bad is that right
that never goes bad is that true yeah i
didn't know that's a great point pimp
and that's that's something else i'd
like to speak to honey out of all these
things is the only thing that is
actually decent for you to put into your
body there is very
there's nothing for with nutella that's
good i mean
peanut butter might have some protein
protein yeah well this is coming from a
guy with a bottle of whiskey in front of
yeah that doesn't matter yeah that
doesn't matter an ironclad argument is
uh is is it would you call honey decency
decency is an ironclad argument for this
podcast to help derosa everyone in
history's had honey
all the greatest figures in history
didn't have nutella or peanut butter
true historically honey's been around
since the ages and also too i'm less
than a race
honey nutella have never killed a small
child peanut butter planted that's a
good point
peanut butter
i will say though for me coming in last
i made quite an impact i'm in the
conversation you're in the convo but
nutella is like band-aid sharpie
windex it's its own thing there's no
knock-off nutella can you think of one
no i cannot there's no knock-off
hazelnut spread no no which says a lot
yeah yeah usually what you call it would
you say what that's that's the word for
that there's a word for that xerox
cleanup yeah yeah yeah what's the word
what a monopoly no no no that's not it
it's when the pri when the product name
assumes the name of the the general
principle of the product like give me a
kleenex you're asking for a tissue you
call a kleenex right or a sharpie
correct i mean it does say here that
nutella uses 25 of the global hazelnut
supply i believe it where else is
hazelnut yeah what else are you doing
yeah
i haven't even seen it in ice cream i
don't even know what a hazelnut looks
like it's a little round that almost
looks like an egg corn oh i know that
one i'll tell you one thing we're all we
all enhance other products
absolutely can't deny it they play well
together yeah i would say we all play
well together that i think the peanut
butter is the one of the three that kind
of fares best on its own if it has to
yeah
or in the most basic way meaning you
spread peanut butter on a piece of white
bread nobody's upset nutella nutella
yeah you know i don't think i don't
think nutella by itself on bread would
be very too much of a treat yeah it's
it's candy it's it's uh but but i i do
agree with that concept yeah but sugar
is like the heroine of food
but look if peanuts kill people
some of the best things on earth kill
people cars
yeah you know it helps
fire heroin water
heroin yeah all the elements yeah
fentanyl whiskey yeah yeah
[ __ ] sex
jacks yeah aids honey's honey you know
where we're sticky but honey's too
sticky it's a little sticky you spill
that you gotta move oh god yeah what do
you think's happening close what do you
think's no it doesn't yeah everyone's
close just right out what are you
talking about honey i don't know about
that do you honey wrong spots what do
you think happens if you spill nutella
on your nice new sweatshirt you're
wearing that's not coming out it's a
chocolate stick oh you're crazy you're
nuts i tied stick immediately stop honey
honey honey gets on you i don't even
know soap takes that off for a while oh
it's sticky [ __ ] crazy it's it's like
natural jizz yeah
beaches we're talking about stains on
clothing nothing stains more than
chocolate or oil-based peanut butter i
got news for you you put natural peanut
butter on clothes that's why that's one
of the reasons i don't like the natural
kind is because that oil will it's oily
but i'll tell you so right now if it's
not natural raw honey it's actually
horrible for you
all right oh
your body cannot break it down but
google it but most people
natural honey is fully accessible and
and i also like this it's fairly priced
it's not you get into a natural peanut
butter it gets very high falutin very
quick they really play you on that whole
vegan raw food angle organic yeah this
is 12 for the jar whatever you can get
organic honey like fairly affordably
give me a
estimate or a middle middle-of-the-road
honey rate
because honey i think could go up in
price pointing down cash should be going
raw organic you want that right you are
you are you're plunging down cash if
you're going raw organic give us a price
put on nutella versus organic peanut
butter versus organic honey tell ain't
cheap either yeah he's coming in a uh
he's going to come in at a 299.99 oh
yeah i'm a man of the people
organically
i want to price an organic peanut butter
we've established we hate that one it
says honey uh retails for about nine to
ten dollars
[Applause]
okay that's for the elite
rockefeller over here with his big fat
honeycomb ten dollars i'll get it free
for six and then the average average jar
nutella is six dollars oh
almost half of the honey that's like
saying that you know oh or oh a snickers
bar is cheaper than an organic honey of
course it is
a hazelnut an hazelnut spread made from
a hazelnut right and hazelnut is exotic
nut it's a treat we talk about treats
peanut honestly is the baltic avenue of
nuts i got news for you it's a
hazelnut in that [ __ ] it's chocolate
spread you're watching i knew they
couldn't watch people
hazelnut
don't no don't don't play along you're
gonna this is where you go crashing you
crash
you're insulting the listener they
they've had nutella they know what it
tastes like you guys want to check in
with the listeners a little bit yeah all
right i'm gonna wrap it up i'll tell you
the best thing about honey is the the
term of endearment that was the best
thing ever came out of honey hey
honey i'm home yeah nobody ever says hey
peanut butter exactly
my little nutella i've heard now you
have it all right let's wrap it up let's
go to the phone just tell us the n-word
is in the house speaking of honey you're
next our next guest matteo lane is in
the house all right go ahead there's uh
honey's for senior citizens and
nutella's for yuppies
a truer statement i've never heard and
peanut butter is for the people all
right for the community
it's uh peanut butter is 100 og stinky
nut juice i think is that good or bad
all right pip let matteo read some of
the comments the way we let mark do it
prefacing his episode okay um
i'd murder a pbj even if i was allergic
it would be an honorable death wait what
do you guys what are you arguing about
that's an american
nutella it's a three-way battle nutella
versus peanut butter versus honey
nutella
would
oh
nutella then peanut butter then honey
crazy that's what i'm hoping that's
candy
all right just read the name yeah what
do you do honey what do you do with
honey you might you buy one bottle of
honey you have it till the day you know
what happens with honey your family
takes it out of the cabinets after you
pass
that's what happens
it sits in there forever yeah all right
really fun
all three will give you diabetes and
glue your mouth shut at least with
peanut butter you have the illusion of
health because it's made out of nuts
true here here okay uh nutty flavor i
could go back and forth on on peanut
butter and jalapeno never honey
nothing makes me happier than a pbj okay
yeah yeah nick
oh pb j man okay let's see um nutella ew
peanut butter for the win
didn't even mention honey
this person says i love honey the most
and people tend to forget about peanut
allergies
this woman's name is nikki and she's
been on every united flight since 1984.
let's see peanut butter was established
during world war ii to meet to meat
storage i think they okay oh due to meat
storage what okay it literally helped us
stop the nazis
let's okay let's also
let's relax here
people in concentration camps like you
know what's going to help us
mixing nuts that's ridiculous hey i kept
those troops fighting hitler
nothing beats peanut butter and sal
volcano better use this poll to promote
saratoga
peanut butter baby we have our own
people money is a byproduct of
life-sustaining animals nutella is a
byproduct of a drunk italian dentist
ponzi scheme all right
[Music]
anthony
you're disgusting spell out his handle
spell on his handle
f-a-g-g-o-t no it's not
no it's not is it no it's not
it's uh anthony
or what is that
anthony underscore flare all right flair
all right pip it's time for the vote
it's time for humble bye let's do a shot
and we'll see where we're at who's
eating it hold on pimp how many votes
give me the percentage breakdown
percentage breakdowns
9 750 votes holy
[Music]
of money uh it was thirteen point seven
percent oh
we got 87 to play with 87 87 coming up a
second place nutella
with 27 points but that's also we're in
america like if this was done in europe
yeah would have won words because they
don't eat peanut butter correct they
don't you're right they do we just found
this out one tablespoon a year average a
per person
they don't eat peanut butter at all you
know who else doesn't eat peanut butter
isis
they hate it and then final place or
first place is peanut butter by fifty
eight point six percent oh
what a crush
is smooth or crunchy yet by the way i
know extra country by the way i never
heard of oh it's out there wow it's just
like full nuts too much it's like when
we went pulp no pulpit yeah one of those
yeah the heavy pulp of peanut butter
just too much obnoxious
all right mark we end by the winner
saying no
plug it in
come on about two weeks okay for dates
if you don't
mark normancomedy.com for dates i'm all
over the road it's gonna be a hell of a
year probably get canceled uh
what do we got here uh tuesdays with
stories we might be drunk out to lunch
on youtube we're about to hit 10 million
help push it over the edge uh stand-ups
on netflix and praise allah i love you
jiff
jeff
salvocano.com for dates
avocadocompany.com for dates again at
the beacon theater on may 14th
la and san diego may 21st and the wilton
and la may 22nd let's get on that hey
here joe derosa info for all dates and
shows
uh punchline in philly and march and
then straight to south by southwest on
the 13th 14th and 15th
of march to do a sandwich panel and some
stand-up shows it's going to be awesome
can't wait uh also hitting the irvine
improv
and san diego for shows in april and
then also coming back to do the creek
and cave in may look at you doing shows
yeah i know good to see you back and
also
like rate and subscribe we always ask
you about that crazy if you like great
subscribers do that it helps us also
come to joey roses nyc
if you're here 174 rivington street
joeyrosesyc.com for all info
yeah march is out right now i'm assuming
if it's out just just go to salvador
countycomedy.com and then all of our
merch might be out it's dropping any day
we're not really sure when this is
releasing but look out for merch good
merch a lot of merch merch
merch all right i missed i forgot i
still love you i still love you baby we
love you too all right honey i'm home
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two foods gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man